[Music]
whena Paltrow and Brad Falchuk are
married in January the couple who have
been an item since 2014 announced their
engagement with a joint statement
writing in part quote we feel incredibly
lucky to have come together at this
juncture in our lives when our
collective successes and failures can
serve as building blocks for a healthy
and happy relationship I'm really lucky
that I found a partner that's patient
and loves me that same month the GUP
founder told ET she wanted a low-key
wedding I think it's like I'm old to
have a big wedding and a big old white
dress and all that like I gotta be like
I got a dial it back on April 12th the
45 year old actress jetted off to Cabo
Mexico with some pals for her
bachelorette party and a few days later
Ryan Murphy who co-created hits like
Glee American Horror Story and scream
queens with Falchuk through the
lovebirds a star-studded engagement bash
in Los Angeles
Paltrow shared this shot on Instagram
with the caption thank you to all of our
amazing true and dear friends who came
to support us and most of all thank you
at Brad Falchuk
for the true happiness
[Music]
[Applause]